somebody said how cringe is this guy for
me asking who's cool are the smurfs or
the rugrats i see that he's in nft in
his profile i know the nft market is
crashing oh so i'm like he might have
just lost a lot of money
i make a video i'm like my man i'm so
sorry you think that about me i really
hope i get the chance to meet you in
real life because i'm feeling we would
hit it off or to that energy not those
exact words immediately gary i'm so
sorry i was being mean like you're not
being mean i got you i love you right
now the biggest issue in our world is
that people think the way you attack
hate is with more hate sure i hate the
patriots i hate the balls i hate
everybody but the jets and the knicks
that makes sense to me but that's sports
that's fake life that's silly that's
escapism that's fun but real life human
beings we need to [ __ ] love each
other and i think it starts with you and
everybody wants to tell everybody else
what to do you have to lead by actions
the way i'm doing that is when people
hate on me i show them love
not because i think it's a tactic or
it's clever or kill them with kindness
it's because it's my true essence